hey welcome to Conan O'Brien needs a
friend and uh some exciting stuff to
talk about today uh joined as always by
Sonam Obsession hello and the sturdy and
reliable
Matt Gourley sturdy yeah he is you are
you are a tugboat beating against the
tide is he he is okay you are very
reliable and uh you're a good fellow
fine fellow more fat you're more friend
he's fragile but but uh but reliable
where do you get anyway yeah he's made
of all cartilage it's okay uh no actual
bones you fight both I have something
exciting to talk about enough of this
dithering and Gathering which is um we
announced uh just a couple days ago that
uh I have been making this show for HBO
Max which I believe is now called Max
um we'll see what it's called in another
few weeks uh but
um it's called Conan O'Brien must go and
it's this idea that's been in the works
for quite a while which you guys are
well acquainted with where as you know I
do the uh
uh I do the interviews uh with
celebrities and those drop on Monday but
then later in the week uh we drop a
interview with just anybody out in the
world and fans fans just fans not
anybody like they can't they have to
know who you are yeah that's only 98 of
the world's population
no you're right it's fans that should be
more specific fans of the uh of the
podcast and I've really loved those
conversations and that's where the idea
came from which is just I love talking
to people so much what if um
and I also used to do travel shows uh
that I that was one of my favorite
things that I got to do all those years
at TBS so the thought originated what if
um some of these guests that actually
end their interviews where they say well
come visit sometime Conan yeah and the
idea came what if I just show up
and so that was the origin for the
concept of this show Conan O'Brien must
go so we uh announced it and they put
together a little Sizzle reel of some of
the episodes that were already in the
can and uh people seem excited about it
you guys did you you saw this as a real
right I I it it pains me to praise you
but I just know a lot of other people
worked on this
it's it looks so good it really looks
good also there's a brief glimpse of you
and me in there and that really UPS the
uh I think that really adds to the show
yeah it's weird because the data says
the opposite uh oh yeah you look at the
data yeah yeah you really look at that
in data in your life
no I I'm a big data guy and I really got
in there and uh I like Micro Data and
mega data and I got in there and uh
massive drop-offs no
um it was uh yeah it's nice because you
see us talking to them and then suddenly
I'm there yeah uh in their face and um
and you surprised them yeah well it's
funny because you try to and some are
easy to easier to surprise than others
but uh it was we put together this kind
of quick maybe two minute uh piece that
uh that ran and um then tweeted it out
and the response was really nice people
seem excited about the show
um the show is uh and this is important
to to point out
the show uh cannot be completed right
now because uh the wga The Writer's
Guild of America is uh on strike so
we've stopped everything and I'm really
looking forward to finishing the show
yeah but uh we're not going to do
anything until everything gets resolved
and uh the writers get taken care of so
we are on hold for the moment
um I feel like you traveling is such a
it's you're so good at traveling I mean
you're good at a lot you're going to a
lot of things but you're really when you
travel you have many strokes when you
say anything nice about me yeah you're
really funny yeah yeah you're gonna have
a neurologist soon say Sona have you
been complimenting Conan recently
because there's a lot of dried blood
near your cerebellum no but when you
travel internationally there are some of
my favorite things that you've ever done
well and this is throughout the course
of your whole career I like it a lot I
really enjoy it uh and
um we have
gone to some great locations we have
some other great locations planned so uh
I just find it kind of reinvigorating to
get outside the United States and meet
people and and run into all these people
who have who have no idea who I am yeah
and find out what they're up to what
they're doing it's just uh and you stick
out
I stick out everywhere yeah I think
I could go to Ireland and stick out it's
just so weird yeah
I'm just I'm just odd looking in so many
ways but uh it's
yeah very quickly uh identifiable but so
yeah Conan O'Brien must go uh on Max
will be coming up but not until uh the
the writer strike uh gets resolved
anyway it's been a lot of fun uh making
the episodes we've made already and if
you want to see the uh the promo which
is fun lasts about two minutes you can
find it easily uh on YouTube on your
channel on your channel your channel
uh and it's called Conan O'Brien must go
and um another thing I should bring up
is that if you are a fan of this program
and you want to talk to myself Matt and
Sona that's always possible we do it all
the time and you never know I might end
up visiting you so uh you can go to
teamcoco.com
call Conan if you would like to reach
out to us and have a chat again that's
teamcoco.com
and you can experience how irritating it
is to speak to me in real time you have
no idea you have no idea